one of my friends came around to my
house the other day and we were talking
about that period of time when I was
making a lot of money and I bought a car
and I bought the car from my mate it was
a silver Pue 106 and I bought it from my
mate for
£710 is what I paid for it and I went to
pick my mate up another mate and he was
like why are you driving this like
car and I said to him like
look if I buy myself £100,000 car some
guy pulls up next in a 200,000 car I'm a
but if I had I'm in this car
and a guy put up in 200,000 car he's a
mhm because that once you start
playing that game there's like you know
you look at somebody like Elon Musk you
know he's the richest man in the world
he's obsessed with getting richer and I
think this is you know a big part of the
story of the book you know we talk about
like the the religious nature of money
is what does it do to people what does
it do to a society when they become
obsessed exactly with money because
money at the end of the day is just a
number but it's a very powerful number
right and it's a very and it's a
hypnotizing number